coming up with our first question for
lauren and team is lauren zema from
entertainment tonight
uh mr michael so many congratulations um
it just an incredible season of the show
you guys did it yet again and this cast
is so wonderful the season premiere is
just around the corner so we have to ask
who will be back there are lots of
rumors that we might not see cecily
again or that pete davidson might not
return what can you tell us
i'm not going to tell you much uh only
because we haven't announced who's
hosting and who the first four are
uh but i don't think anybody will be
heartbroken
you don't think anyway we'll be
heartbroken i think people will be happy
with what we have
that was me being a baseball team
for us about the sorry can you tease
anything about the second season or
about the new season for us um
no no i can't i think it's all going
it's all going out next week and we're
just finalizing
uh one thing and so and we always do it
tell the first four shows at the same
time
and there's some new casts
and they'll be announced this week too
are you planning any tribute to norm
mcdonald
and
can you tell us about
how much he's impacted you and the staff
and everything just his legacy
um
i i think he meant the world to the
people there i can tell you from just
the number of people i've heard from the
number of people
that have gone and talked about norm all
of us had uh
you know when you work with somebody for
that many years and uh
and they make you laugh and and uh
you're aware of
who they are as a person and uh and as a
friend
i think norm was uh
one of the funniest people i've ever
known and because he's canadian i put
him right there up in the top five
and who's hosting
[Laughter]
believe me there are people you've heard
of
okay
thank you yeah thank you anthony next up
we've got joe fryer from the today show
and nbc news go for it joe
hey there lauren
thank you um jason zedekis just won and
took the stage thanked you but realized
you weren't there because you're here
talking with us right now but what's
your message to jason
i was so happy for jason and uh uh
he'll be coming back soon
uh tessa nell so i'm very happy about
that as well
he'll be coming back soon yes which is a
sort of an answer to the first question
but
in no particular order
all right congratulations
thank you joe okay and now a question
for david from extra go ahead david
hi david hello lord congratulations
everyone thank you thank you
um
i guess my question is about uh norm
mcdonald i wonder if you have a single
memory that stands out what you'll
remember most about him or a single
moment that comes to mind that you can
share with us
um
it was a sort of uh
when he was at the show
i was always
just in awe of how long he could take
to tell a joke
and how long he could pause before he
told another joke
and he let the
he he never uh pandered
do you know what i mean he never
uh he was always gonna do it the way he
wanted to do it and and if you waited
you were really happy you did so
uh
i call it integrity but it's uh prop
integrity's probably been mentioned 50
times tonight
but he had integrity
[Music]